[Music]
welcome to another night of chess on
psychology
i am trying to come up with a new name
for it so if you have any suggestions
let me know um
today
we are finally
one class away from wrapping up sicilian
as white
i still have to go over rouser i forgot
about that momentarily but
we have done uh we've been doing
sicilian for
the past couple of months so
um
well ideally
if you still have questions on it either
leave it in the comments or go watch the
previous videos about the sicilian
playlist to be fair i kind of done i
kind of wanted to do a sicilian playlist
because caleb did assist in his black
playlist a while back so
it was more
you did it as black i'm gonna do it as
white type of deal
and um we had dennis bars here i
might have scared him off
it's fine he'll be back but
so if you have any questions comments
concerns
let me know i am reading the live chat
the audience or not
um okay i think nikki has a
proud game which hopefully will show me
in our next segment of
switch to twitch
where we analyze your games
um
all right so i'm gonna just go ahead and
jump in
so today we are gonna start well not to
start but wrap up guns and roses which
are mike selechnikov we did last week
kalashnikov we're doing this week and a
little weird uh queen b6 stuff that
we'll also cover because i had some
fun and some virtual experiences with
this so better to know than not to know
another small part just to mess with
tracy
so she forgot to log off her accounts
from youtube here so if you guys want me
to type in anything in the chat and
pretend to be tracy i can
so we can do that too
all right um
all right let's go jump in oh there's a
question what's the topic of the class
sicilian we've been doing sicilian for
the past few
months
yep pretty much since late november
so
we should be done with it
not this week but the week after that
so
let's
jump in this time
all right uh let me also kill the noise
here last thing i need is
hearing the moves so much fun whoops
didn't do it okay
so um we
oh um there is a question and there was
a lemon no
well guns and roses resulting we did
mention
d6 bishop b5 i personally didn't have
that great of an experience with knight
c6 bishop b5 so
it's not my
amazing recommendation
i do like it but i prefer d4 much more
so um
all right so d4 take take
and
now
there are multiple ideas here that
black can do
first off if g6 then we got c4
transfers to moroxy which you can go
watch the video we did previously
um there are some d6 ideas which d6
can transfer to rouser like knight c3
knight f6 bishop g5 which we will do
next week
um
hello fake maurice ashley
there are some queen c7 some queen b6
which we'll do a little later
and
finally
last week we talked about the e5 ideas
more in depth we're going to continue
talking about e5s now
and we talked about
whoops
ideas surrounding knight of six
or or actually early night of six is
also a
huge possibility
the one thing that i've always wanted to
try but somehow i never did i don't know
why is this
why do you think this is a bad idea
nah i should have
not given the smile
but why do you think this is a bad idea
yep you're right queen at5 just hoping
to trick somebody
but
well
yeah be careful with your forks
so yeah i really wish this would happen
but it can't
so that's why we usually play this
e5 knight
up
and d6 now bishop g5 and now we got
slesnikov
which
we talked about last week right
which would be seven or b5 and
a lot of funds
so
a lot of a lot of other things also can
transfer to switch takeover so be
careful with that
after um
so now we're talking about kalashnikov
which is just a small difference in move
order but it kind of prevents your
bishop g5 so let's say e5 knight up
let's say d6 we're gonna come back and
talk about a62 but now remember if your
knight was on c3 the opponent knight
does on f6 you would have bishop g5
right
but now you don't have that bishop g5 so
what i wanted to talk about was the c4
now
uh you can play knight c3 but if you
went ahead and played this knight c3
then opponent doesn't necessarily have
to play knight f6 they could start with
like a6 kick your knight away and maybe
go b5 and a or bishop e7 and they can
just continue delaying knight f6
so i'm not the biggest fan of this i
kind of like c4 no more d5s for you no
more b5s for you yay
um so in this specific case
let's say we go ahead and
jump into c4
however
there are
multiple things that black can do right
now
in the
by
you know black doesn't want to play
knight f6 just yet if they play knight
f6 then we still get our bishop g5
sooner or later so a huge thing in
kalashnikov for black is that they they
want to delay their knight f6
so
i'm gonna just take a little bit of a
side note and talk about a6 before i
forget because i do this i keep getting
too deep in a whole different line i
forget about this mini line that i want
to talk about so let's talk about it
right now what do you think we should do
with this guy should we give the check
or should we retreat
also saint louis is extremely cold i
flew back from london yesterday and
london was hotter than saint louis this
time of year so i'm just
i miss
also uh the la the in-person audience i
do not see you so just feel free to
speak up whenever you want
i know you're there but this light is
really blinding so
dorsa i'd like to take a minute and
restart the screen capture it's working
it's just a little bit slow
sure
let me uh
for a second i thought that was my cats
do i need to do anything
can they still see me
okay
can
cool
we good
awesome
so speaking of a6
now yeah the 96 is pretty cool
sorry
but the problem well not a problem but
you kind of have to know how to play it
so they're going to take because if not
then king e7 nobody wants that
take take and let's say they play queen
f6 now what do you do
yeah a6 is definitely playable but white
needs to know how to continue and i
really need to clear my throat
do i cover the mic before i
alright
what should we do
uh queen exchange is um
questionable because
you
this this night that was up here you did
one two three four moves just to help
opponent develop so that then you can
just exchange queens yeah nah
you can but you're gonna be in trouble
because opponent is just gonna attack
you with tempe and tempe and tempe and
so
queen d1 yep now let's talk about
this position because it's weird right
you got two bishops you got um
weak dark squares
but in return actually light square too
but in return you have no development
absolutely another
so what should we do about this let's
say opponent plays queen g6
now what do you do
exactly we're kind of setting up for the
next game
yeah
uh well you have to know what to do and
knight c3 is the best way to go about it
let's say they develop and this is this
is kind of a fun way h4 bishop e3 is
also interesting but h4 is something
that i tried too and i had fun with
um
the idea is simple this queen is
bothering you not letting you get the
bishop out you just want to kick it
if they stop it then you can block it
again you want to move this bishop
you have to be cautious with these d5
ideas
because when you take it
then there can be different night moves
and attacking this guy
so let's talk about for example knight
d4
now let's get the bishop out defend and
attack
they will do the same take take and
queen d3
i'm relatively comfortable with this
let's say they take with the other
knight again whoa
whoa that was fun
now you get queen d3 right and you're
trying to castle
uh let's say now i'm going to take a
moment because i don't want to just tell
you everything so what do you think bla
white should do after f6
g4 whoa
the pawn can just take it though
also what if the pawn just takes this
guy and i take then they can take back
nah
be careful this bishop is actually under
attack if you castle they'll take it
so your your main idea to consider
should be bishop back to e3 so let's say
bishop e3 they take now what do you do
yep good choice
and now let's say they trying to
continue simple ideas because they also
have to start
wanting to save the king and another
point
is
you might have some stuff to do with
these knights maybe take it right now
maybe
try to play f4 to weaken it you know you
have a lot of ideas so queen f3 try to
block this bishop movement and pawn
movement now what do you do is white
i kind of like this knight e4
yeah makes sense thank you nikki yeah
it's kind of a
weird situation in the center to be
honest
uh because you know we want to try to
open it up but at the same time we can't
do that that easily
so
let's see what do you think we should do
right now
what do you think let me actually help
you out with what i think black should
do let's say black is following the
logic and trying to exchange of queens
right weak king extra pawn let's see if
we can exchange off queens
wait why am i getting queen b6
to be fair taking is alright
but um i don't think this would be my
first choice personally because i would
uh hope for
more excitement
with the queen
right now you i mean opponent still has
to figure out ways to save the position
and develop but
i mean queen b3 makes
more
well sorry taking first makes more sense
if you take
then i can simply take back with a rook
if you take now i also have fun of four
ideas
this end game is better for white i'm
going to just scroll through and show
you how for example it's good turnout
fun pass pawn really weak pawn
when do we get d6 i'm quite excited
about that
yeah that's fine too
yeah so this is how it could for example
turn
turnout
this is again just an example it doesn't
have to be the exact thing
so
let's go back back back
even more
back and all right we're going to change
gears
and talk about knight b4 now
still same problem but bishop d3 can be
more problematic because then they can
take it and then you would get stuck
with double pawns so why to move what do
you think we should do
did i pull on something
cool
hello iron
i see a push to deep on
i
also see it take on over here
wait
yeah i'm fine with this idea
taking might be the best one now if t if
if they actually attack over here and
they want to eat that then what do you
do gotta move the king so what do you do
what are we thinking about
yep king d2 i agree fully
let's say they stay with the commitment
because if they don't then we're taking
it so let's say they take now what do we
do
d6 yep thank you chad
yeah d6 save this guy
actually it's kind of like in their eye
but save this guy you want to eat this
little guy
and
yeah your king is on d2 but it's not the
end of the world for this king so this
is totally fine i am very comfortable
with this position
so
all right
yeah i mean there's a i guess there's a
mention of bishop d3 as well but no i'm
fine with this the bishop d3 you have to
be careful because
there could be like some e4s or some
bishop of fives and you might want to
avoid getting yourself into
uncomfortable positions like that
it would be
ideal to
not let your opponent get slippery as
you probably hopefully remember we've
done a few segments on slippery dorsa
so i've shown you some of the
super weird games that i should not have
not lost but i did
so
i managed to save it either win it or
draw it
so um
yeah be very careful
we do not want
to let opponents um
get away with
i was going to say murder because
there's tv should have been pinching
but get away slip away let's go with
that let's keep things
nice because
you all know i can
start talking about weird tv shows way
too fast
yes that's true
um
all right
lets me
go away yeah i want to talk about this
take and ah here what if they take back
that was one thing that i wanted to talk
about
yeah i i watched dexter too i haven't
watched the new season i kind of want to
but i'm almost done i just finished
season 13 of criminal lines
so it's like two more seasons left i'm
too committed at this point
um
so i have to finish that first
sorry
it's too fun
mentalist is on my to watch list as
i need to find more chill tv shows i
watched the rest of development and i
felt like i actually started to use some
of the puns and it felt weird in you
know real life society
so that was not that was not a very
practical tv show
yeah but it was fun to watch
all right so k7 what do we do
kind of stop thinking about tv shows now
if possible if you have good
recommendations seriously do let me know
i'm running out of stuff to watch
i mean bishop d3 is kind of nice because
you kind of have to at this point if
take then queen takes queen takes now
this end game i kind of want to get out
of a i kind of want to get your
evaluation on it what are we thinking
crash landing on you whoa
i'll i'll keep that in mind i'm
not sure how i feel about it but i mean
whatever i watch is probably better than
a lot of things i've already watched so
all right so what do you think end game
wise
yay or nay
well i mean white definitely has a
little bit of a
[Music]
little bit of a thing going on but i
agree
it might not be as easy as you would
want it to be
so for example
for example right now a set point plus
b5 then you can get the king up or play
a3 and this is a fine position but right
now i also saw in chat d6 whoa d6 was
something that was mentioned
and i think that you guys were correct
d6 is a pretty good idea
because now after d6
let's say
they go king to f8 what do you do then
oh
anything any feelings
well to be fair i wouldn't really call
this a blunder because if they do end up
taking it we take they take we get to a
long castle
and
if leeches makes the move thank you
leeches and then
here we can simply
let's say king moves
kick the knight say night moves we give
another check this is really great i'm
i'm loving this position i'm not really
concerned about how to continue this
so
yeah d6 taking is just in our benefit so
let's say the king goes back
now we get bishop d3 and if they take
it's like the same thing but we push the
king away
so it's even a little bit better
this is completely fine for white
uh let's say
they go d8 again we can do the same
thing
and wrap it up with the long cast though
i guess i mean rook h6 is still a
possibility
uh but if f5 this kind of still weakens
their position so with knight g5 they
can't take just yet because i have
knight f7 right
so i'm i'm i'm fine with that
all right
okay that was way too deep way too
unnecessary all right let's just go back
there was only one other line i wanted
to mention i'm going to do a big jump
here
because we talked about knight t7 now
let's talk about d5 and then we're going
to wrap up a6 so d5 what do we do
should we take it
oh
it's possible but if you take with the
queen then you have to be careful with
possible knight d4s or bishop e6 so do
you have answers on those
well let's start with knight b4
what would you do if knight goes to b4
yeah you're right
that's great i'm happy with that so
let's say bishop e6
i would try to pin the bishop
ah
but then rook t8 can also again get
problematic
if there was no rook d8 i like this but
with rook t8 it gets also very scary
because now you actually have to deal
with
possible threats like this
make sense yes great
so that's kind of why queen d5
brings the queen out to the line of fire
way too early
um
so
whoa that's kind of why i like the idea
of taking with the knight a little bit
more taking with the pawn possible two
but the night before and then this is
another problem
if we get out there then they can take
we take they can take
i'm not liking this that much
even if knight d4 you do that and then
they can just take this and
so that's why taking with the knight to
actually threaten something big as well
so now let's say
um
let's say
they take over here
what should we do now
yeah we don't want to we don't want to
give up on unnecessary powers
i think i see something like a tracy
all right we gotta stop the check what
do you think is the best way to do it
let me put the t somewhere else so i
actually don't do what i did last
not last week the week before that
i'm getting a lot of bishop e3's
i don't think i i think i only have one
or two bishop e2's people are definitely
more
voting for bishop to
e3
yep i like bishop e3 let's say now they
do knight d4 again attacking you and
that guy
so what should you do now
97 is getting a lot of love so let's
talk about that okay all right okay
knight c7
let's say
hmm
yeah i definitely do like this
so let's say knight c7 then
king got a move fair
now what should he defend this or pick
this guy up
it's a lot of tactics here
to be fair i've never had this position
i've had a very few kalashnikovs happen
to me in over the board chess a lot more
in blitz and in online chess but uh
still like this is kind of a
crazy
crazy line so um
i wouldn't
i wouldn't think too much on it
if you don't play this um just gonna
know the main ideas i'm just kind of
trying to show you that how crazy it can
get
and how important it is for you to
actually know it but you don't have to
obsess over it you don't have to feel
like oh my god i don't remember that one
line and move
20 and yeah
okay man i wish i could take this
legally
so all right let's talk about the
defensive move first let's say rook c1
the problem is bishop g4 another attack
now you go queen d3 you can take and
then you know this is still a
comfortable position
but
still a lot of a lot of small
problems
so
let's say
you still push they still defend i'm
just gonna shine you this is all
computer line i looked over a little
while back
and i'm just gonna just i'm just showing
you some of the possibilities of how
crazy things can get
oh boy
again you do not need to know this line
to this depth you just need to know
where your pieces belong what is
something that your opponent really
wants to do and
how can you stop it
right
so let me go
a bunch back
now we talked about rook c1 and they
were like eh maybe so let's talk about
queen d3 now
let's say they take this with check now
what do we do
i see that a lot of uh dm yes you're
correct
we're trying to do the
i can never pronounce that i just kind
of kind of call this guns and roses
instead of
low-end dull
sicilian
i'm 100 sure i just said that completely
wrong
but
uh these are all kind of in line with
kalashnikov so
let's say we got to move the king yep
let's say they take take
they take that now what do we do do we
take this back or do we take that guy
i agree
let's say they're trying to save the
horsey well i mean the knight
now what
thank you thank you ben for the poll
because
i'm going with that
now what do we do let's activate some
pieces yep let's get them activated
let's continue activation and i'm i'm
fine with this position i mean black
still has a lot of stuff that they can
do so i'm not really
that comfortable with it but
i think i think this is fine
this is a fine position
right a little scary but nothing we
can't handle all right i'm gonna do a
jump big big jump
okay actually a ginormous jump so we
talked about d5 we talked about queen g6
and i just want to briefly mention this
guy
i mean scary because you have advantage
but it's kind of hard to actually be
able to
use it
because opponent has a lot of different
ways that they can bother you
how are we doing
okay let's get pieces out yep again this
h4
again you can also have a fun game which
is bishop e3 but i think h4 makes it
even spicier because you aren't possibly
not entirely sure which side you want to
castle but it does make sense to keep
your options open
so
um
let's say now
they play h6
see this is immediately a very fun
threat
let's get the bishop out let's get ready
for potential long castle
and
finally can we get this long castle
thank you yeah yeah see
yep long castle would be fun
all right
that was a long stuff
all right i'm sorry to move on from this
part we don't want to talk about that we
don't want to talk about that we want to
talk about not a6 now so d6
oh boy that took forever
okay so d6 remember how we initially
started talking with d6 and then we were
like
[Music]
let's move on and talk about a6 for a
minute well that minute took about 30
minutes so
for d6 it's important to be aware of how
you should play which is you can't play
bishop g5 you don't want to play nice to
um
c3 too early so let's say you go c4
you're going to prepare for knight c3
all right so bishop e7 there are vision
v6 as well knife bishop e6 i'm kind of
comfortable with just getting the piece
out
getting knight a3 and i'm gonna follow
up with bishop e3 and i'm going to
continue
possibly short castling because if you
know i've already played c4 i don't
really feel comfortable going long
castle
so let's say something like this yeah i
can just short castle
if they go for example bishop e7
now what do you think we should do
hello s.e
how you doing
i mean 93 was a
force so troy boy
are you all right buddy
i like the idea of bishop d3 the main
thing to consider right now is this guy
over here is
how do i put it delicately
useless let's go with that
so um you know it has a it can be
purposeful when it comes to c2 it stops
this knight to d4 it may serve as a
knight d5 idea so i like that
so for that reason i think it might be a
nice idea to
go on ic2 first now another thing is
when they played this bishop e7 without
knight f6 they might want to pile up and
play bishop g5
which means they would want to exchange
off these bishops which in return means
if these bishops are often knight d4 and
the d4 square which is outpost
uh gets too weak for us so with knight
c2 we kind of hold off on it
we still have to take it we don't really
have much of a choice there but now
our d4 square is already covered
so so the other
many things that we can do
now as h4
is queen d2 i'm not that big on queen
detour to be honest but it's doable
knight e3 not that big on knight d3
either or knight d5
knight d5 i kind of hope when they take
somehow my knight could take it
so the ideal position because of the
pawn structure would be to get rid of
this bishop and one night
and
wait
yep
and wait i really want to eat this
though
yeah the ideal pawn structure would be
to if we could kind of get rid of
this and keep a knight versus a bishop
because the position is kind of closed
so if we could keep one knight versus
that bishop that bishop could have to
be constantly defending here this is a
weak pawn that we could continue
attacking so
it's a lot of fun
h4 is
fine
however let's say queen goes back and
then you would have to move this queen
possible but are you really going to go
long castle
i'm not saying no but i'm saying ah
you have to you know be aware of long
castle c files open possible b fives it
could get really
really crazy
actually somebody's asking why not take
why not take let's talk about that
seriously why not
yep a little bit of a problem with this
oops
yeah i worked it it's not going to be
fun let me just tell you that
so
let's say we don't allow
checkmate
queen d2 is a possibility
i really like it though take take
uh it's playable but
do you really want to play this end game
i know i don't sorry i know i don't
all right
the other thing is
how about nice e3 let's talk about that
so far h4 feels like the
the most logical continuum but i'm
hoping to avoid that so let's talk about
knight to 93 they can go knight d4 then
what do we do
i'm seeing some some stuff to see too
but we just came there
i'm seeing some stuff to d5
maybe
maybe now knight d2 kind of weird right
let's set it take we take or d8
castle it's kind of a
ah not not my not my type of scenery
yeah
i don't really like this that much i
mean white has a tiny bit of a more
comfortable position but still h4 seems
to be the better one now finally what
about knight d5
what am i threatening with knight d5
this right if they take it i'm pretty
happy because i actually get take it to
the c which means i actually win this
guy well this file knight moves away
knight e3 i improve my knights i'm
joining over here so let's say they
develop i give a check they can't even
play b5 right because i'll just take it
yay let's say they move then again this
is way too comfortable i'm very much
loving this
so they can't take it so let's say they
go rook c8 now what
i see the chat is taking their time
did i possibly
startle you
chad is quiet
okay oh g3 yeah thank you
thank you to super wait to see bakura
i like that let's say they get that we
get out f5 now what do you do
g3 is pretty cool i agree
all right so
now let's say
i like it thank you comedy and
entertainment and to
sue bakura
not lovely let's say they move they cast
lola castle this is a very fine position
also black has to play so many correct
moves
good for them
yeah white has white is more promising
because white has a tad bit more space
like something queen side king side
center white has more control whereas
black is just kind of in a more
defensive style
black hopefully i mean black is kind of
hoping to get some stuff happening
in the queen side slash center maybe but
the king side is pretty blocked
let's say we just play b4 now they can't
even take it comfortably because now b5
and they have to deal with another
weakness
yes the king is not as comfortable as we
would hope but at the same time i don't
think that's a huge problem because um
well to be fair they're not really
attacking it if they have if they for
example had a bishop here yeah i
wouldn't be as comfortable so
hopefully that makes sense right awesome
and
actually this question why not take
what's
what's
why not take yeah
let's talk about that
yeah yeah you're fine because if take
them the bishop falls we don't want that
so yes you're right take back with the
knight also attacking the knights
so let's say they hit this guy
and then we continue attacking we could
have also taken over here
so that can happen next move too not a
big deal
and
yes it's kind of chaotic
um
but
they can't cast though we can
that's a huge difference
um when i do end up castling my king is
safer than their uncasted king i have
the chance to open up center my pieces
are better than their pieces so because
of the tiny advantages here and there we
have advantage overall
so
yeah
all right cool
uh okay that was a ginormous line so if
they do wish we said on bishop g5 we
can't take
so the
funnest ones the most fun ones
we're h4 and knight d5 so i'm kind of
gonna leave it up to you to make that
decision
oh boy that was a big one
now number bishop v6 talks what if
bishop v7 already
should we still go knight c3
we can there's some weird b3s you can do
this you can do that you have a lot of
options
i'm fond of knight c3
if they attack me i'll come back and now
black has three ideas either get this
knight out either get this bishop out or
some weird f5 i don't really want to
spend too much time on f5 because with
f5 we can simply take
and then follow up with bishop d3
and you are eventually going to make
this maneuver
the only big difference when f5 happens
is that
the d5 square out that d5 outpost square
is no longer as weak as they were hoping
it to be so taking is a is a you know
it's a big change but it's completely
fine
and i'm just going to kind of show you
how
it could get really interesting
now
this is still strong pawn you have this
going on for you whoops and your knights
are really good how do we get the bishop
well b3
and we can try to activate it from
different diagonal
for example
and this position is completely fine for
white
and the main game is going to happen in
the queen side though so just keep that
in mind
there was one other thing i wanted to
mention
ah yeah bishop e2 is also possible not
the biggest fan because knight f6 and
you know still the same ideas but i kind
of really really like this
bishop d3 more if they take well
hallelujah because now this is the true
weakness
they can't really stop it from happening
i exchanged off my bad bishop with their
good bishop so i'm very fond of that
so that was f5 i mean can go more in
depth but that was kind of the big part
of it
there is knight f6 as well now with
knight f6 you can start with knight c2
or you can go bishop d3
a lot of the ideas are the same so
you're just going to have to come up
figure out what new order works best for
you
and for example i'm just going to show
you let's say knight c2 first nice it
does fine but you might be giving up the
b5 square too early let's say they go
bishop e6 you just
very comfortably you're trying to
develop and out of the out of nowhere
you get f5s wait you get f5 ideas you
get b5 ideas so what i'm trying to say
is you can't play it too chill you still
have to figure out how to
defuse opponents threats hopefully
yeah
even though if they're not actively
trying to play f5 or b5 it doesn't mean
that your position is
safe so you can do whatever you want
that's something that i really see
very very very very often with players
of any level they just get comfortable
in the position all of a sudden and then
they just lose control of it so
don't do that
and finally
let's talk about bishop d3
and now again you're going to do the
same ideas in the queen side
this is a weakness we would love to
attack it if we get 93 even better
if it don't that's fine too
d5 square is going to be a huge part in
this and this is a comfortable position
black has some ideas in the king side we
have a lot of ideas in the queen slide
white is overall more comfortable so
that is one thing you should keep in
mind
okay that was a lot of talking now
if bishop b6 first again you can
continue with either bishop d3 knight c2
or bishop e2 again similar ideas
and again you are going to want to get
this knight to e3
you're going to prepare for it you don't
want to lose control of the of the d4
square too fast
you're just going to prepare and this is
a very comfortable position black does
not have too many long-term ideas so um
yeah
be very mindful on this
all right there was
one other line that i did want to
talk about
however briefly we're going to switch
gears just a little bit and jump to boom
there we go queen b6
come on leeches jump come on
good little leeches
all right
it's gonna be a real quick idea
oh sorry there is a question um what is
the queen side weakness do you attack in
the central pawn yeah the d6 and also
when we have a pawn on c4 and we have
rook on c1 we can start pushing b and c
so you don't really have a
weakness in your king side so black is
just kind of trying to poke around and
find something but for the most part you
are fine
all right so this queen b6 idea
how is this how is this working out for
you
so queen b6 um what i like to do ouch is
knight b3
followed by knight c3
and then i really really like this a3
because i just don't want bishop b4 if
bishop b4 gives opponent happiness i'm
gonna take it away
okay that
probably sounded
meaner than it was intended but
yeah seriously if opponent is gonna do
something just take it away don't let
them have it so a3
now the only thing with a3 that you
should be aware of is
sometimes you might actually want to do
long castle so if you have a3 it's kind
of uncomfortable but i've had a lot of
experiences with bishop before so it's
just
no it really bothered me so i just went
for
a3
and i've had multiple opponents playing
a6 with me
and um this is this game is a while back
i actually had this game in um
nine years ago oh that hurts
yeah i had this game nine years ago um
it was i remember it was the last round
of asian eu championship
2013 it was a second time i won it
so and i went for bishop d3
come on bishop d3 and my idea was simple
i'm gonna just you know go bananas on
the third rank
paid off
and the idea is this kind of looks like
a cheveningen because a lot and if you
go back and watch the seven ingredient
videos we really talked about f4s we
talked to a lot of bishop to e3s the
knights were kind of similarly placed
so yeah this is a this is a lot of fun
and again if you go back and re-look the
german engine videos we also talked
about some possible g-force
and in this specific game it paid off
you have to be very careful when you're
doing stuff like this but to be fair it
was the last round i had already won the
tournament and i just wanted to
go bananas so
yeah and like see opponent already
starts to break under pressure and she
was a very reasonably rated person she
was sorry she was like 1960
um very federated so
she wasn't
the she wasn't unprofessional
anyways
so i immediately got a nice attack
immediately
and again now i just want a piece
and the rest of it is kind of just too
easy because i had extra material and i
just
really really wanted to do tactics and
she really lets me so i was very happy
about that because
you know it's just tactics
beautiful beautiful bishop chickmates
i think you want to end it right now
because this is as best as it gets with
the position
bishop checkmates winning asian youts
nine years ago oh my god
but yeah um
we're gonna take a quick break
and go to
twitch
when we're gonna go analyze your games
so
have your games ready for us join us on
twitch
and in about fiveish minutes i gotta go
pay some respects tries to come up here
and switch to twitch
and next week we will finally have our
last
sicilian
ever actually that's not fair not ever
but the last sicilian of this playlist
so it was a pleasure being here um
yeah have a great day every week
bye
[Music]
you